[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 que hoy dedicamos al arte
contemporáneo chileno con una exposición
excepcional en parís llamada utopías
latinoamericanas que presenta por
primera vez en la capital francesa la
obra de la cantante y artista visual mon
laferté pero no sólo junto a ella ocho
talentosos artistas consagrados también
chileno y todo esto tiene como epicentro
la galería bahía utópica de valparaíso
por lo artístico de chile y tenemos con
nosotros a sus galeristas a nancy
arancibia muchísimas gracias nancy para
ser con nosotros y también una vez
bienvenido curioso por invitarnos bueno
lo que han hecho es como deslocalizar su
galería de valparaíso al centro de parís
en una galería efímera con la apuesta de
nueve artistas
contemporáneos todos chilenos aunque
algunos vivan fuera de chile como en
españa argentina o méxico y hay varios
denominadores comunes en esta selección
son obras comprometidas
sorprendentes y con discurso en que se
diferencia la apuesta de estos artistas
con lo que se puede ver en parís de arte
contemporáneo
de américa latina que venimos de un
continente distinto de valparaíso que un
puesto de fin del mundo los artistas
tienen que jugársela para sobrevivir y
vivir tener un discurso
actualmente el arte contra madrugada con
muchos colores es mucho más discurso
porque hay muchos problemas políticos
económicos en chile o en américa latina
en general entonces los artistas ellos
quieren participar de todo entonces
vamos con una propuesta para
diferenciarnos también de lo que podemos
encontrar en parís para existir nosotros
hay tanta arte en parís que para
realmente que no puedan ver tenemos que
sorprender entonces vamos con un arte
colores américa latina hasta colores
pero también con un discurso un
contenido
relativo a las circunstancias actuales
con las contingencias y también como
otra dirección ironía o sarcasmo en
danza y cómo está siendo la estos
días de esta exposición muy bien ha sido
excelente
nos gusta mucho cuando entra sobre todo
un parisino cierto que diga que es una
maravilla que es excelente el nivel eso
es lo que más a mí me emociona como
chilena de estar acá con los artistas de
valparaíso de chile y que digan que es
de calidad que es buen nivel eso es lo
que nosotros hicimos nuestra curatoría
era buscar cierto un buen nivel en el
oficio en el contenido que se pudiera
leer cualquier persona que pasara eso
creo que se logró el reclamo principal
es mon laferté que recordemos es
cantante y activista es artista
multifacética chilena que vive en méxico
y cuyo trabajo musical es archiconocido
y también multipremiado con mi grammys
latinos en tv europe music awards esté
aquí también está postulando a cuatro
grammys latinos pinta desde siempre pero
tal vez esa faceta sea menos menos
conocida
quienes el mont artista artista visual
con la suerte
si su papá y pintor hiperrealista y ella
siempre en su familia siempre han
desarrollado hasta y visuales siempre ha
pintado dibujado pero después su
trayectoria su carrera la dedicó
principalmente a la música y dejó un
poco de lado la la pintura hasta que
hace como 10 años creo que era de
retomar en serio hasta no confesó que
cuando va de gira siempre va con un
atril pintura era pintando y nosotros
como orgulloso porque fue la primera
guerrilla en chile a hacer una
exposición individual con ella fue en el
mes de marzo febrero más o pasado y fue
un gran éxito ella era muy feliz de
poder mostrar su trabajo artístico
visual en valparaíso porque de la región
de valparaíso
tienen una pequeña caribia propia a ella
en méxico y había hecho también una
exposición en el anuncio de la ciudad de
mexico
entonces eso no con foto en su talento
hay artistas consagrados como luis
martínez maestro del dibujo y otros más
jóvenes como martín riveros
con una apuesta
porque el pintar digamos la así que qué
aspecto les llamó la atención nancy para
atraer la parís
justamente porque es a diferencia de
todos los otros artistas porque trabaja
la psiquis o sea el interno mental y él
está estudiando está estudiando con
psiquiatras tomando clases como los
antiguos maestros de la pintura que se
dedica a estudiar y claro y el ahí de
alguna manera a ciertos plasma en su
tela lo que él quiere decir con esperar
lo que él va entendiendo desde un punto
de vista interno mental es perturbador
es cierto porque él es un artista hiper
realista pero a los 15 años ya era un
maestro
pero quiso hacer su propia obra él no
quiso trabajar desde la fotografía sino
que buscó un tema que lo pudiera plasmar
cierto su oficio su técnica de libre
organismo que los artistas
hiperrealistas saben de qué se trata y
lo lleva al máximo pero que no se puede
fotografiar digamos
el graffiti es un elemento esencial del
arte en valparaíso hay una muestra en la
galería de la dupla un color distinto
con pequeños cuadros de acrílico y lápiz
en tela que lugar ocupa el graffiti o el
street art más ampliamente de valparaíso
en la evolución del arte contemporáneo
chileno bueno hay una gran tradición de
muralismo en américa latina por la
propaganda política por la decoración
también por muchas cosas entonces y
valparaíso siempre fue una plaza un
lugar donde se desarrollaban murales el
arte el 67 de valparaíso como siempre
salió otro lugar un poquito más tarde
un color distinto en uno de los actores
más importantes porque hace casi 15 años
creo que empezaron con los rayados los
graffiti y terminaron con el mural lo
más alto o lo más grande de que está
actualmente en chile y han ido al rincón
de un mundo y valparaíso se transformó
en spots donde todos muchos artistas
quieren ir a pintar y a mostrar hay un
turismo que se desarrolló también que va
para solamente ir a verlo todo que está
hecho en valparaíso es eso forma de
embellecer la ciudad las leyes son mucho
más libre que están en parís entonces
mucho más fácil de conseguirse un número
de pintada de poner colores y de manera
influyen en el arte contemporáneo que
sale de valparaíso eso se refleja
otros artistas
aclaro porque actualmente hay muchos
artistas que llegan desde el extranjero
a valparaíso y que quieren pintar es una
ciudad geográficamente muy interesante
para el graffiti porque es un anfiteatro
entonces tú te estás ciertos desde abajo
desde la costa mira a los cerros y está
muy lleno de grafitis lamentablemente
como es patrimonio de la humanidad o sea
nos dijo como lamentablemente es un
honor ser patrimonio de humanidad pero
hay reglas comenzaron las reglas donde
no se puede pintar y ahí han habido
algunos problemillas pero como el el
arte del graffiti y la pureza el arte el
graffiti es hacerlo así rápido y
arrancar como dicen ellos entonces son
los que tienen más valor estos chicos
llegaron fueron los primeros los
propulsores pero hay muchos otros de muy
excelente nivel nosotros trabajamos con
ellos hasta ahora bueno decir que son
los son muy importantes pero hay otros
también los hay un cuadro que me ha
llamado especialmente la atención
un grupo de modas de la isla de pascua
que están navegando en una pequeña
embarcación creo que es una
embarcación hinchable es una obra una
obra del 'juan pablo neira
de la que hay muchos cuadros en esta
exposición me gustaría que abanderamos
un poquito en la obra de este artista y
el significado de estos más que parece
que estén diciendo bueno chao
son los refugiados climáticos
se van porque la ue está subiendo y hay
un volcán además del humo y se escapan
de la isla de pascua
ubique una referencia también a los
reflejados en general en los refugiados
climáticos entonces ver todo eso es no
hay una embarcación y cuidando como
fuerte impacto antes de hecho una obra
que impacta mucho a la gente que llegan
en la galería el 'juan palo negra de una
artista que está muy ligado a la
contingencia y le gusta denunciar con
ironía o con humor también la sacó lo
que está pasando en el mundo para venir
en parís trató de buscar también
temática que era más universal porque
también desarrolla un trabajo que era
propio a chile que en chile tenemos un
estadio sociales de 2 año que también de
fuente de inspiración pero en este caso
quiso decir que sí está también chile
tiene un problema climático bueno la
gente no necesariamente saben que la
isla de pascua pertenece al país sin
proceder a valparaíso porque la región
administrativa de valparaíso entonces
era como un guineo para decir sumó
delicia de pascua más encima actualmente
como hay en chile una asamblea
constituyente que ya ha un guiño también
al pueblo originario que están
defendiendo su derecho actualmente con
la nueva constitución entonces neira le
gusta mezclar muchas cosas y le gusta
también dejar el público imaginar
interpretar como quiere en la galería
también hay obras de otros artistas
comprometidos y en los que está
influyendo también justamente todos los
cambios que está habiendo en chile
tenemos las esculturas de pablo villegas
que es una escultura de denuncia y que
utiliza como elemento de creación los
casquillos de bala
es que los casquillos de bala que lo que
hay dentro de un casquillo y claro él
está denunciando claramente lo que está
pasando con la vida de los seres humanos
en nuestro país esa es un poquito más
específica él está haciendo un estudio
del de lo que es la necro política y él
quiso también
ilustrarlo en su escultura y es fuerte
pero es todo es una realidad y no
solamente en chile yo creo que la zona
desde artificio en el mundo están en
todas partes que eso trata un poco la
negro política les quería preguntar en
buenos tiempos de pandemia los que
estamos viviendo
de hecho ustedes venían a parís para
participar en el cabo dictó ampliar una
feria más amplia de arte contemporáneo
que no se ha podido hacer que se
suspendió es difícil dedicarse al arte
en estos tiempos es muy duro que
nosotros en el año entre el año 2020 y
2021 estuvimos 11 meses cerrados
sin poder abrir las puertas no éramos
muy adictos a la tecnología
porque como trabajamos la pieza única
trabajamos la obra original nos gustaba
que el público fuera a la galería que se
enfrentará a la obra y eso hacía llamar
a que fueran a valparaíso nosotros somos
amantes de la ciudad de valparaíso del
puerto al país y si estamos allí difícil
provincia pero lo que queremos atraer y
que pensábamos que que esa era la forma
vengan a ver el arte original tenga la
oportunidad de sentir de estar frente a
este potente espíritu del artista hemos
desarrollado herramienta tecnológico
virtual internet instagram todo eso
cuando llevamos a cabo y de hecho
también hemos hecho una convocatoria a
artistas para que representando arte con
temática de la pandemia e hicimos la
convocatoria y después resultó una vídeo
con la obra premiada pero era totalmente
virtual que nosotros siempre hemos
defendido lo lo presencial bueno pues ya
no nos queda más tiempo solo recordar
que están en el madre en parís hasta el
21 de noviembre pero luego se trasladan
a un solo lugar privado también en parís
a la feria de street art a mediados de
enero del año que viene que se celebra
en el distrito 13 de paris muchísimas
gracias a los dioses nancy de ajó y
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir en internet en rf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]